have you ever wondered folks and Julie
for that matter what incentives make
employees work a little bit harder is it
social rewards to drive people or
perhaps financial ones like your yearly
holiday bonus our next guest has it all
figured out dan Ariely is professor of
psychology and behavioral economics at
Duke University and he's also author of
the new book irrationally yours and and
Robertson Abbey video is still here with
us Dan great to have you back on market
makers hey nice to see ya so what works
social rewards a cold hard cash okay so
let me describe to you the experiment
let's see if you can predict okay so
another quiz I feel it's definitely a
quiz earlier this morning miserably okay
so this we did this experiment at Intel
chip manufacture and this is a place
where people come for four days they
work for four days very long shift
twelve hours days so they have four days
on and then four days off four days or a
job function they make chips got it and
what's nice about making chips is we can
measure how many chips they make right
if I try to measure your productivity a
little hard to figure out there but you
know people who make chips we have some
output measure now on the first day of
the first shift Intel gives them a bonus
they say if you perform at this level
you make let's say 1,300 chips we'll
give you $25 you don't make it zero so
it's a threshold and then no bonus on
the second day no bones on the third no
boss on the four four days off back to
the bonus so that's what they do we said
let's do a control condition let's have
another condition in which we give
people nothing right just compare the
cart with nothing nothing then we said
another condition how about if we give
people Pizza Pizza Pizza like a social
thing right well yeah okay it turns out
it's very hard for the HR department of
Intel to send people Pizza complexities
beyond me but they agreed to do a
voucher for pizza so it's not exactly
the same but you know it's said you're
taking out the whole community
environment over working along the edge
own it together it's fun and we did one
last thing which is to send people a
compliment so we have four groups one
group is getting a compliment they come
on that day and they say if you perform
at this level you'll get a nice text
message from the boss
one group is saying if you perform at
this level get a voucher for pizza one
group if you perform at this level get
$25 and one group gets nothing which one
of those four do you think before yes
let's guess compliment money voucher
nothing compliment compliment I'm gonna
say compliment okay definitely not the
voucher very good so you all know of
course it's trick question because you
wouldn't invite me otherwise but here's
what happened on that first day of the
first shift all methods money Pizza
compliment worked better than nothing
and they all were identically better but
here's what happened what happened on
the second day
remember on the next day there was no
bonus involved mm-hmm but now things
happened why because the people who got
money on the first day worked harder
when the second day they worked 15%
worse than a control condition whoa it's
as if they said yesterday I worked hard
you gave me money today there's no money
I'm not so interested right so they went
up they went down and then they slowly
went up back to the control condition so
in total by giving people this money
until lost about 5% of productivity and
by the way that's the thing they were
doing generally so we went to them we
talked to the managers and we said look
your intuition was so wrong right you
created this bonus because you thought
it would help clearly not only didn't
help it hurt your performance we said
let us maybe even change the
compensation for the top management
maybe your intuitions about that is
wrong as well but you know they were not
interested in in those experiments by
the way wait what happened to the other
rewards so the text the text message on
walls went up in the same way and went
down slowly but never backfired and
pizza was somewhere in the middle now
and you can see how if pizza was more in
the social realm like more like real
pizza it will probably look more like
text and if it was more transactional
would it look like the money and this is
the thing you know there are so many
jobs in which you rely on people
goodness to perform at a higher level we
can't create a specific contract here is
how much exact you getting there is a
lot of discretionary effort and the
question is what gets people to want to
exert more discussion
effort and look we have to pay people
and we should pay people well but what
gets people to do more discretionary
effort is often not a little bit more
money but instead it's something that
they care about but isn't this the
problem with the financial industry
before the crisis when it was all about
getting paid the most amount of money
possible then the crisis hits regulators
say you can't pay people anymore they
realize how much they hate working at
banks and how poorly they're treated so
so that's the question of you know what
was money is a function of before the
financial crisis and I don't think money
was just money it was keeping score it
was feeling appreciated I spoke with the
head of a big bank and I said you know
what happens when you give somebody a
bonus of more than a million dollars he
said we give them the check and we don't
even smile at them I said you know I
actually own some shares in your bank I
think you're not doing the right thing I
want you to give them a hug if you can
give buy them beer and give them and get
them more motivated yeah I was enticing
you doing this yeah people like and and
he said no no we would never give
somebody a hug or buy them beer I said
look this is this is crazy right but
here's the thing
money is both money it can be a
substitute for lots of other things and
I think in banking it's been substitute
for lots of other things but we're not
doing it the right way Andrew does this
square with the research you've done
absolutely video absolutely reason
drives to conclusion emotion drives
behavior if you can do things that will
stimulate the production of either
dopamine or or oxytocin you create a
very is that what we're talking about
dance what creating an emotional people
hug so so you know oxytocin is is a very
interesting neurotransmitter that gets
us to basically have higher social
coordination and care more about other
people and now ask yourself how much of
your job or anybody's job is the thought
that we have is end of your bonus versus
the thought of the year is what do other
people expect from you but what are the
people around me how do I facilitate
them and and then this idea of complete
and incomplete contracts right so if if
you really rely on the goodness of my
heart what would get me to be a bit more
interested is it is it something that is
delayed no it is
in close in close proximity need
something about the people people around
me there's lots of wonderful ways to get
people to care more money is one of them
but money is often not the most optimal
one and it's kind of a shame because if
you say let's structure the enjoyment of
people with money and other types of
incentives everybody could benefit right
you could get people to produce more and
be happier at the same time